hello I'm johnny depp tonight you're
going to watch a review from ryan right
about my movie The Lone Ranger people
are saying I do a bad job and I play a
stereotypical Indian well yeah The Lone
Ranger the movie that critics hate but
not this guy now don't get me wrong i'm
not saying i love the movie i thought it
was just okay there were certainly flaws
with the film people are giving Johnny
Depp a lot of crap for this and honestly
I thought I was gonna suck yes I'd say a
good eighty percent of his performance
is Jax Federer was an Indian what for
some reason the you know the squints the
white eyes and you know though I think
that giant up does it's still [ __ ]
entertaining for some reason he keeps
doing it in like every role now but for
some reason I still find myself laughing
when it's in a movie like this he
elevates the movie with the humor of
Tonto and yes I want Johnny Depp to join
the club I'm gonna suck his dick one day
Johnny Depp throat and Armie Hammer
playing The Lone Ranger you know that
the guy that no one [ __ ] remembers
who ian is that here's that face up I've
seen that [ __ ] guy before but where
have I seen him from in case you know no
he's the twins in the social network he
is both event you know kind of like how
Michael Keaton played multiple people
and multiplicity so anyway Armie Hammer
people give this guy [ __ ] too I thought
he did a decent job a decent job okay
decent is okay for a guy who's probably
nervous playing the lead when he knows
everyone's looking for Johnny Depp he
probably had some pressure on his
shoulders leaving that aside he still
did a good job with really i believe his
bravado i believe his you know why fight
for justice and i don't like guns you
know obvious stuff that's gonna be no
obvious character comes throughout the
movie but i enjoyed that and the best
scenes in it work johnny depp and armie
hammer when they were just playing off
each other it was really funny it was
great to watch it makes you kind of wish
he had a little indian friend
and you know I mean there's there's
great humor and then it's like it's a
fun western action movie you know I
don't think people understood what they
were going for with this film it's a fun
western action flick you know it feels
like an old-school Western it's you know
people are saying it's bombarded with
action what [ __ ] move your are these
people watching there's like three
action scenes in this movie the great
action comes a little late into the film
actually pretty lady to the film but
still it's pretty damn good action and
he doesn't I mean they're striving for
characters here it's an Okie blockbuster
sure it's not great but it's a fun
Western action play but it's also some
great supporting roles this guy you see
making never [ __ ] remember William
Fichtner in case you guys I know he is
he's got at the beginning of the Dark
Knight you and your friends are dad he
plays the villain of the movie where
there's some she has a thing for eating
human flesh there's cannibalism in this
movie you know that's that's one weird
thing about this film is it's really
violent and it's pg-13 when it was it
seemed very close to being a rated r
movie at some points with this guy is
eating out a person's heart it's a
little rated R dish for me but you know
what he embodies the role and Barry
Pepper barely in the [ __ ] movie but
everything is in its like good old Barry
Pepper still intriguing the [ __ ] out of
me and you know what to the production
design the production design I think
everyone can agree on was great to look
at there was great costume was great set
pieces great makeup effects because
there's this old Johnny Depp in the
movie they show old Tonto you know he's
narrating the movie when you have first
see you hey anything like Tony DETT but
you know that's Johnny Depp under the
makeup do method actors put makeup on
their penis you know like if he's old as
you make his penis like all gray and
wrinkly I will suck jolly that's dick to
find out and there's some great music in
this film to you me people think music
for granted i think but the score in
this is pretty damn good it has hans
zimmer songs and them so you know i
think people would be too hard on this
movie if a film is just above good i
think it's worthy enough to recommend
let me get straight to the point here oh
and all i gotta say the lone ranger did
get it right
alright guys thanks for checking out my
show why don't you go ahead and you know
scroll to the comment box below and tell
me do you agree with my opinion of the
Lone Ranger I need the rebellion guys
Rotten Tomatoes has hundreds of cranks
and then going to go ahead and follow me
on twitter you can click this link right
here and yes I will follow you back cuz
I want to get to know you and if you
want to see a more in-depth review of
the Lone Ranger this for video I
recommend washing it's a from my other
show called reasons to see it's
basically where we give you reasons to
see and not to see and really own two
deaths more of a podcast I the show a
lot so at least you wanna get updated
every time one of my reviews is up go
ahead and click on this subscribe button
right over here and you know what this
Rangers feeling a little lonely if you
know what I mean so lady is one should
comment below and give me your number
because this Lone Ranger it's oh so
horny